charmé pas si charmant un court métrage
réalisé par une équipe de six cinéastes
en herbe un projet de 20 minutes qui
fait écho à l'actualité
on était un groupe avec des jeunes et
des moins jeunes donc voilà ça nous a
permis de mettre en place une bonne
dynamique et c'est un court métrage sur
ce qui se passe avec des méchants virus
qui arrive à un moment donné ce qui se
passe quand on est une petite
collectivité
le projet résulte d'un atelier organisé
sur plusieurs jours par l'association le
cinoche
il permettait d'apprendre les techniques
du cinéma sur smartphone c'est un
atelier sur ces quatre jours continue
donc tous les jours on est venu pour
travailler avec thomas et enzo qui nous
ont bien coachés et puis mes camarades
de tournage grâce à cette expérience les
comédiens amateurs ont pu découvrir
l'envers du décor hélène nous raconte
une anecdote de tournage
tout d'un coup on s'est mis à entendre
un marteau piqueur juste à côté
et c'était la boucherie à côté qui
venait refaire entièrement le magasin
donc là on a eu un peu peur et puis on a
quand même pu arriver à travailler avec
eux
quand tu travailles pas en faisait nos
tournage donc voila un petit peu les les
aléas des fois de du cinéma une équipe à
présenter son film au festival de courts
métrages sur smartphone organisé par le
cinoche à magny les hameaux charmer pas
ces charmants a reçu le prix coup de
coeur du public